le plan blanc vient d'être activée à
l'hôpital de blois
cela signifie que le personnel va
pouvoir être rappelé en cas de caen de
congé et que les interventions non
indispensables vont être reportées les
différents services vont désormais se
concentrer sur la gestion de la deuxième
vague
un dispositif de crise déjà déclenché au
chru de tours
selon la rs ce mercredi en
indre-et-loire 24 personnes était en
réanimation contre 23 la veille en loir
et cher six personnes sont toujours en
soins critiques et derrière ces chiffres
que l'on vous donne régulièrement il ya
heureusement des hommes et des femmes
qui ont surmonté la maladie et qui vont
mieux mais pour une raison que l'on
n'explique pas encore une petite partie
d'entre eux gardent des séquelles
plusieurs mois après leur guérison
fatigue sévère trou de mémoire aux maux
de tête
c'est pathologie persiste chez des
personnes qui n'avaient pourtant pas
développé une forme sévère du
coronavirus exemple avec dominique un
habitant de tours-nord rencontrées par
romain delville dominique a contracté
lakovic 19 à la fin du mois de février
une grosse grippe pendant une bonne
semaine
puis plus rien jusqu'à fin mai c'est
alors que de nouvelles c'est qu'elles
sont apparues fatick sévères crampes
trous de mémoire une sorte de covin
chronique qui perdure aujourd'hui j'ai
les muscles qui qui se débat ni jésus
est comme un sportif finalement qui va
comme un mec finalement qui va faire un
effort physique très violent et et qui
va être pour ceux qui connaissent un peu
le sport qui va être lactique ou et
serrage je suis et puis j'ai pu y a pu
rien dire que le j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya pu descendre organiste et ça ça va
survenir n'importe quand n'importe où
cet habitant de tours nord estime qu'il
est devenu confiné mentalement depuis
l'apparition des nouvelles pathologies
c'est pourquoi il a réduit ses
déplacements bien avant leur confinement
j'ai aussi cette peur d'eux
ne pas me sentir bien de faire un
malaise d'être fatigué des terrains en
grosses scènes nous protéger j'ai donc
je reste chez moi et donc je dis bah non
je vais pas aller aux villes où et ses
jeux réduits des distances jeu réduit
les activités de naturellement alors que
al'inverse parfois je me dis qu'il
faudrait peut-être que j'en fait plus à
67 ans dominique était content de ne pas
avoir été hospitalisé pour qu vide
mais n'imaginez pas avoir autant de
peine à se remettre de la maladie